-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy Friday!
Happy Friday, everybody.
Everyone's excited about this.
Today, The new movie "Creed III"
hit theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's some of
the most brutal
fighting you'll see on screen
without Andy Cohen
sitting in the middle of it.
I'm telling you that right now.
Let's get to some news.
I read that
in the coming weeks,
former President Trump plans
to "amp up the attacks
and name-calling" on
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
[ Laughter ]
That's actually a nice
change of pace.
Usually fights between
Florida guys
take place
in a Waffle House parking lot,
but Trump said he was
going to up the name-calling.
So get ready for three straight
months of "Moron DeSantis."
[ Laughter ]
It's weird when a guy
goes on a name-calling spree
against someone who has
almost the same name.
It's like, "What kind
of a crazy name is Ronald?"
[ Laughter ]
"That's the dumbest name
I've ever heard. Ronald.
Imagine if I called
my son Ronald Trump Jr."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it seems like
Trump and DeSantis
are really going to attack
each other's differences,
but the more you
break it down,
they actually have
a lot in common.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "Similarities."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Similarities ♪
-For example, DeSantis thinks
he can beat Biden.
Trump still thinks
he beat Biden.
You see?
They have similarities.
-Very similar. Yes.
-Yeah. Next up,
DeSantis wants to distance
himself from Donald Trump.
Trump wants to distance himself
from Donald Trump Jr.
He's like, "No thanks.
Oh, hi, how are you?"
Here's another one.
Trump flew classified documents
to Mar-a-Lago.
DeSantis flew undocumented
people to Martha's Vineyard.
So he has some similar.
-Very similar.
-Yeah. Then there's this.
DeSantis wants more control
over Disney World.
Trump wants to build
a wall around Epcot.
"Make fake Mexico pay for it."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, DeSantis wants
to ban "woke" books.
Trump wants to wait
for the movie to come out
before banning.
"I'm not going to read that."
And finally, Trump loves
the Dallas Cowboys cheerleaders.
DeSantis loves dressing like
That's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, today, I don't know
if you saw this.
Trump released a campaign video
calling for a national contest
to create futuristic
"freedom cities."
[ Light laughter ]
Somehow this is going to end
with a Statue of Liberty
in a bikini,
I just -- I just know it.
I just know.
Trump has a lot of big ideas.
He also proposed adding
a second Saint Louis arch
and painting them gold.
[ Laughter ]
Interesting.
Some news
from the White House today.
President Biden hosted
German Chancellor Olaf Scholz.
Yeah, Biden met with Olaf.
It went better than
when Trump met with him
and said, "I was
expecting a snowman."
[ Laughter ]
You don't have to build it.
In my future city,
no one has to do anything."
Get this.
I heard that a scientist
found a super-rare
Jurassic-era insect
at a Walmart in Arkansas.
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah, I mean, it's ancient.
And good news -- it was
immediately hired as a greeter.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
--Hey, we have to laugh
at ourselves, you know?
Finally, researchers
just discovered
that winemaking began
11,000 years ago.
Yep. To find out more,
tune into the new Bravo show,
"The Real Housewives
of Mesopotamia."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show.
Let's go write
some thank you notes.
Today's Friday.
-Really?
-Yeah, that's usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
-Really?
-Oh, yeah, I get my --
-What else do you do?
-Well, I check my inbox,
return e-mails, of course
I send out thank you notes.
It's Friday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Would you guys...?
Would you guys mind
if I wrote out
some thank you notes tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right now?
-Now.
-Now?
-Yeah, in the middle
of the show.
-Wow.
-James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
I would love some.
[ Piano music playing gently ]
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
Why is it...?
-Wow. That's the
Miami Sound "Asleep" Machine.
-Yeah. Why is he...?
[ Laughs ]
Why is he so excited?
-I don't know.
He loves the conga.
-Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, Ron DeSantis,
for being on a mission
to destroy two Donalds --
Trump and Duck.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-[ Imitates Donald Duck ]
Uh...
♪♪
Thank you, Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle's eviction
from the royal residence,
for leading to the most epic
U-Haul procession ever.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Get it out of here!
-[ Imitates trumpets playing ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Mandalorian helmet,
for looking like Iron Man
with Ozempic face.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Ozempic face.
-Vitamin O.
-[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, Subway building new
restaurants with playgrounds,
for being perfect for anyone
who's walked into a Subway
and thought, "If only
my kids could play here."
[ Laughter, applause ]
-I guess not.
-♪ I can dream ♪
♪ I can dream ♪
♪ I... ♪
The National's here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Japan finding 7,000 islands
it didn't know existed,
for being the global version of
finding $20 in your coat pocket
and you're like...
-Hey!
-Awesome!
[ Applause ]
-Nice!
-Do the conga!
-Do the conga on this.
♪♪
-Thank you,
powdered donut holes,
for looking like something
Cocaine Bear
left behind on the trail.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa. Whoa!
Hello.
-That's exactly it.
-That's it.
-That's Cocaine Bear scat.
[ Chuckles ] Scat.
-[ Indistinct ]
♪♪
-Thank you, pistachios,
for being nut clams.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-That sounds filthy.
This is a family show!
-Nut clams.
-Nut clams?!
-[ Laughs ]
-Wait a second.
I thought you were being clean.
-We got one more joke.
-One more? Oh, my God.
-You think I can't top that one?
-You got to top nut clam.
-Oh, no way, man.
-Clam it up, G.
-Here we go.
Here we go, G.
♪♪
-Thank you, KFC,
for bringing back your
Double Down sandwich...
right in time for the finale
of "The Last of Us."
There you go, everybody.
Thank you!
Those are our thank you notes.